per i ragazzi e benvenuti a nessuno b e
vabbè cos'è sta roba siamo suo kikuchi
cui è un gioco che ha un nome bello però
è comunque
da attaccarsi addosso teoricamente
minato finalmente sono qua penso che il
mio zio a cui abbia lasciato una chiave
in fondi fra tra porta vicino a statua
del buddha ok a imita chiave chic e bon
nonché vorrei entrare qua dentro bra
effettivamente tabto si decideva o mi
fate usare joystick o mi fatto usare che
controlla cioè decidete qui non è che
posso dare un teatro c'è un insetto di
me
davanti alla chiave io non l'ho
toccherei con la mano mi fa un po schifo
examined
graziela lasciamoli sto schifo l'insetto
va bene ok è che rosso come il mio cane
quell'insetto c'è qualche problema qua
posso entrare quindi sta porta o che
devo fare
yes amòdio che reinhard you che narra i
thunder dei boss quella storia di sotto
i tavoli vediamo o gli
hives take action
ma posso entrare nel tavolo da di sopra
divertente ma è un sack e bar è un bar
dove fanno il sake frigo non è che siamo
tutti ubriachi minato a due stelle
ok c'era un tizio con una maschera
orribile questo è tutto sa che è che
figata
buono e scusa che questo non sa che
barbuto
a quello è un soldo
saleh
io volevo del sushi che sta lì però non
lo prendo facciamo che vado di qua va
bene posso a non posso c'è una bambola
che mi sta fissando malissimo posso
andare bene mi scusi chiedo
gioca a nascondino con chivu a quelle
occhi curva bene perché ci sono soldi
tipo comunque questa sono marce o kiku
giochiamo a nascondino
ma tu conti dove i due conti dove devo
toccare per liberarmi tanaliberatutti
dove sono un metodo vedevo arrivare come
faccio giocare eccoci a io devo trovare
lei a figo ok divertente non vedeva
l'ora di giocare asta cacace non è tanto
grossa la stanza dovrebbe ecco l'amica
che crepi è capissimo detto dei rumori
qualcuno che sta sfidando qualcosa non
so aiuti c'è un'altra poco
salve la zia bello sto cesso non l'avevo
visto successo voi [ __ ] i soldi dalla
cassa
successo
sta andando a fuoco cesso possiamo
uscire mimino non è proprio il posto
opportuno dove andare a fuoco fino alla
porta almeno posso uscire di quanti
chiedono per tutto lo chiedo per
cortesia te lo chiedo per cortesia cioè
un ora che sono qua ancora non si è
pagato dovrei farlo prove ragazzi l'ho
rifatto fino a questo punto perché non
riuscivo brignole ai beta non riusciva
ad uscire però dovuto riavviare il gioco
di fatto fino a qua per prema che non so
come le riavvio le luci se posso
chiedere visto che non ne ho la minima
idea donna le dio però vabbè lamela
magari a prima della luce al suo punto
che te devo dì no no non ho idea di dove
andare per riavviare le luci non possono
uscire esco
arrivederci posso chiudere dentro ecco
perfetto a posto ciao
l'ho chiusa dentro sta andando tutto a
fuoco però fa niente e dove si riaccende
le luci sarà qua un quadro
sarà un quadro elettrico che non ho
visto tipo eccolo qua lo zio
eccolo qua zio ha posto
molte oric a mente
ok posso passare grazie gentile no è il
controllore che controlla che le custode
veste molto largo a
gradisce le tagli xl non so se ve ne
siete accorti quindi è normale che se
investigate rooms and a voice o kiku
cece lavori do io lavoravo idos tutti io
santo benedetto e con la volta poi e
corri però guarda tempo
hanno mai visto e mi sono spesso qua eh
volevo avresti voluto vedermi ma non mi
hai visto a me è proprio visto non è
l'intelligenza artificiale suo gioco e
proprio levata comunque non vedo lo
investigare l estate
hai visto che c'era una versione di the
un po più grossa non so se si è accorta
ormai tanto la zia mi segue quindi se ne
frega posso usare questo ex amin protein
amici un codice da inserire piccolo
protein
non lo so la zia la smettiamo basta dim
il codice è chiusa la porta bene latifa
continua a mandarmi a poco il kolossal
beh sai mica al codice perché ci sono 35
no dai mi sono incazzato di nuovo ma che
palle ma perché è così facile pagarsi
sto gioco perché devo trovare un codice
questa scatola che non ho trovato ancora
non c'e l'obbligo a meno che non sia
scritto due some inaspettato
ma eccolo qua 7 questo 7 ok
ahi ahi smette di spingermi 3713 togliti
tanto non mi fa non mi fa niente cioè
danno non è che mi non mi fa danno 7 13
lett.d o rotaie sa
bene cos'è che cela dentro
ce ne sa che
c'è una chiave ottimo grazie
tech
grazie stato pico trovato una chiave non
solo da farmene proposto per me che c'è
una porta che non visto
acqua ma [ __ ] da tp rimasta è
rimasta indietro però ce n'è un'altra
per una volta che pensavo di aver finito
va bene
io chiudo la porta si sa mai che quella
torna
ok nuovo jet nuovo obiettivo localizza
il tempio dio kiku e impara dal suo
passato io veramente vorrei non imparare
come andare a fuoco visto che è la zia
saranno formalmente però ben salde non
si tirano testate agli ospiti cazzo era
c'era qualcosa che non ho visto
fortunatamente c'è una mela molto carino
fu
questo è il tempio di oki q
io vedo solo un sacco di roba lì porca
[ __ ] poco sono cagato nelle mutande va
bene c'è un sacco di ceramica spa cabile
qua
datemi la mazza madonna che ciao ragazzi
non c'eravate prima mi fa piacere che vi
serve mica la festa però non so chi e
c'è poca gente epoca il poco spazio qua
nel tempio di oki cui io farei
devo andarmene dal sa che pare resta ora
secondo me hanno bevuto un po troppo sa
che qua dentro e non vorrei dire meno
male che è rimasta incastrata nella
porta arrivederci
ap suu kyi saleh
porca [ __ ]
porca [ __ ] bisogna cagato è finito
così
non ho capito no grazie tuo zio ha perso
il ristorante nel fuoco e la polizia sta
cosa che ha dominato
fin e quindi spero che vi sia per
ricordarvi di tenere un estintore e
poche bambole saprete un'attività di
ristorazione
perché poi un casino e noi come sempre
ci vediamo forse anche rare lasciato mi
piace e non lo so ma benvenuto che non
so più che dire di giulio gioco rivale
beh ragazzi
[Musica]